one las vegas man continues to do
everything he can to help orphans in
need all across ukraine we first
introduced you to mark davis when the
war started now he is back here at home
and he is asking for everyone's support
our sasha loftis caught up with him
after spending months in ukraine helping
children survive russia's invasion
mark davis is back home to tell his
story the whole world is learning what
real evil looks like the las vegas
native runs abundance international a
non-profit that houses ukrainian orphans
and as war rages on take a look these
children are taking cover underground
and his efforts to keep them safe are
crucial just one week ago
a bomb exploded in the playground at our
orphanage and mikolai blowing out
windows in the building and fortunately
there were no children there in the
weeks since the bombing began davis has
traveled across the country to make sure
every single one of them stays clean and
fed these are kids we held
you know these are kids who made little
crafts for us at christmas
after just a few days here in the states
he's heading back overseas to continue
his work there's little bits of miracles
and warmth you know in mixed in with a
tragedy but mark and his team still need
support
so he's asking those who can to donate
and help these young lives find some
semblance of normal again
after so much hardship your prayers are
creating miracles sasha loftis live
local now
and if you would like to help abundance
international we do have a link on our
website